if i was a government official and i was
hell-bent on just completely stomping
out bitcoin
and i was based in america
could they do what they did to tornado
cash and just say the entire bitcoin
blockchain is now on the ofac list and
anyone who touches it i mean
theoretically they could right
theoretically they could i've never
heard anyone talk about no no i but
yeah the you and every other lawyer
would be lined up outside the court
ready to have a field day
but
it does open up so it opens up this this
is this is an attack vector for any
any protocol and so every protocol and
all developers working on these systems
communication systems for transferring
value or just communication systems in
general
should be
rigorously
testing
and and having really serious
conversations about whether or not their
technologies are sufficiently
decentralized to survive something like
that bitcoin will survive something like
that um it'd make it difficult for us in
the states to transact um but it would
survive
you know the technology and
infrastructure would survive the u.s
user
could be quote unquote frozen out right
right from uh from this
what it then brings into is this whole
thing like decentralization is really
freaking important it's really important
right um but just because you have the
decentralization
that protects the protocol that protects
the the tech itself right
it doesn't necessarily
have the same impact on the individuals
because they are still subject to the
individual citizens and this is where
you need base layer privacy um base
layer anonymity and bitcoin's not
doesn't score great on that um there are
tools you can use
um that are similar to mixers but are
different
um
coin joint tools and things like that
where you can
obscure and regain you know forward
anonymity in your transactions
and those types of tools are desperately
needed because that's the piece like you
said that's going to allow
individuals to continue to use a
decentralized network you know there are
privacy coins and privacy protocols that
have that built at the base layer and
they make different trade-offs that
bitcoins made but that's the that's the
key that's that's what's needed is is
privacy and anonymity and and
the problem is is we live in this you
know bank secrecy act regime where
there's no your customer
regulations and
it's really hard
to
participate in these protocols
um these cryptocurrency digital asset
protocols without going through
these kyc processes and these kyc gates
now like it's it's really difficult you
can do it
um but it's not user friendly
and that's where
you know and i'm not an engineer if i
were that's what i'd be working on i'd
be working on you know
those privacy tools anonymity tools
that um
you know help us
and help individuals participate in
these in these protocols anonymously
hey you did you like this video great
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time